looking for a movie that celebrates
Irish stereotypes more than the quiet
man well Darby O'Gill and the little
people is the film for you yeah I'm not
gonna act like a lot of this isn't
played up to the nth degree and over the
top it oh yeah it can be painful at
times but again
to its credit there's a real charm that
goes along with it
they have very likeable actors they have
a lot of heart the effects are
unbelievable even by today's standards
and the story is just a great hodgepodge
of all sorts of things Irish and goofy
and mythical and legendary and all that
fun stuff so what's the story Darby
O'Gill is an old man who's trying to
find the king of the little people he
always tells stories and bars about how
he comes across them but of course
nobody ever believes him
but Darby's destined to prove that he's
right and he comes across a well that he
falls down through easily the worst
effects in the movie seriously with all
these other groundbreaking effects you
couldn't do that one a little better and
he comes across King Brian and his Merry
Men
they say they has to stay there forever
but he manages to slip out and King
Brian goes to capture him back
Darby takes advantage and captures him
instead and every time he's trying to
prove someone that he actually captured
the king of the leprechauns King Brian
always has some sort of trick to fool
him again so that's one story going on
the other is that Darby has a daughter a
beautiful young maiden named Katie
well Fairley is being courted by Sean
Connery yep Sean Connery and on top of
that he sings she is my dear my darling
one my smile and I'm Big Island one I
loved the ground she walks upon
my darling Irish girl yep there's
nothing like a Scottish man doing an
Irish accent while poorly dubbing his
own voice in a musical moment but things
heat up when Katy is on death's door
only in Irish lore it's not the Grim
Reaper that comes for her
it's the Banshee a lot of people may
remember that I put this as the number
one scariest nostalgic moment and
everyone's are called bullshit on it and
yeah maybe they're right maybe it is a
little silly now but I'm sorry this
thing still scares the shit out of me
especially we opens the door here that
is scary as fuck yeah the effect is kind
of dated yeah we know how it's done but
just know it's just so creepy and that's
kind of one of the nice things about
this movie even though there's a lot of
chipper upbeat things in it there is
also sort of a dark undertone that's
throughout the whole thing the things
that the people want to do in this are
actually pretty mean
Darby tries to feed the leprechaun to
his cat or the leprechauns try to keep
Darby there for the rest of his life how
Darby tries to rob them on several
occasions there's headless Horseman's on
carriages it's kind of messed off it's
kind of like a dozen Aesop fables being
went together with Irish lore and it
works out pretty well and still creates
for the most part a pretty flowing
narrative the actors I think find just
that right mix of charming and kind of
goofy the guy who plays Darby is pitch
perfect he is just so enjoyable
he can't reminds me of a white Uncle
Remus it's just how can you not enjoy
his stories how can you not enjoy every
single time he opens his mouth and
starts talking he's just freaking
delightful Sean Connery though pretty
unknown at the time it's actually a
pretty good lead in this too I swear to
God
Darby's daughter must have the prettiest
most adorable smile in this oh my god it
just why eat her up even though she's
not dubbed very well either he is my
dear my darling one his
so sparking full-on over no I can match
the likes of him you actually really
feel this sense of community in this
town you feel like you understand them
and actually kind of want to know them
more you kind of want to go to this pub
or you kind of want to work in these
fields or you guy don't want to eat
dinner in this house I don't know
there's just something very homely about
it that I really like though yeah I
don't know how Irish people would
necessarily look at it because kind of
obviously it's a bit over the top it's
kind of like how the 70s look back on
the 50s and we got grease this is kind
of how white Americans look at Irish men
and well this is the product of that but
I think it's hard is in the right place
and like I said I think these actors are
just so good and so charming and so
likeable and the effects are incredible
and the music is great and oh there's
just so much to like in it so it's hard
to say if you're an Irish person I can
vouch for it and I could be totally
wrong in saying that you won't get
offended you have every right to be
offended if you offer but just know that
a lot of people nowadays know that this
is played up as well and enjoy it
because it is just so fun and silly
especially if the people watching know
that it's played more for goofs and
laughs so I say it's definitely a fun
flick and we're checking out